foreign
good morning everyone and welcome to
this meeting of development control
committee a mid-suffolk district council
my apologies we've started a couple of
minutes late may I remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements please can you
ensure that microphones are turned off
when not in use please do not interrupt
other speakers or hold separate
conversations whilst others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt you may be
asked to leave and please ensure that
mobile phones are on silent or switched
off and that your laptops are switched
to silent
we'll be using an e-voting system for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please could members make sure they're
logged in and ready to use the app if
possible I'd like to remind everyone
present this meeting will be broadcast
live on the internet and will be capable
of repeat repeat viewings the whole of
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being reported
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or trading purposes
the council members of the public and
press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
you do hear the alarms please leave the
building immediately via the fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
at Ipswich Town Football Club follow the
signs directing you to the fire exits at
each end of the floor please do not
enter the atrium the ground floor area
and walkways
if you're in the ancient at the time the
alarm please follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit
please use the stairs and not the lifts
and do not re-enter the building towards
till we are told it is safe to do so
okay so just quick introductions
um we have uh Gemma Walker the area
planning manager in depress our legal
advisor will have case officers coming
for each application and we have the
governance officers Clearfield partner
this to Norman uh we have uh in
Mid-South District Council the ward
members may speak on an application in
their Ward but may not vote so if you
see someone crossing the moving their
seats that will be the reason why
okay we'll move to the first item on the
agenda apologies for absence and
substitutions please do we have any
apologies
thank you chair we have apologies
uh councilor Stringer is substituting
for counselor eban and councilor War
boys discounts is substituting for
councilor Matheson thank you thank you
very much
do we need to receive any decorations of
disclosable pecuniary interests and
other registerable or non-registerable
interests by members
yes
start down this end
s in my world is known to be personally
yep thank you chair item C I would
declare an interest in that item and I
will take no part in the debate as I'm a
director of the John Phil Center who is
the owner of that building
so maybe leave the room for that item
yeah thank you
any others yes cancer field
yes just on the first item seven I I do
know Robert Baker who's um
involved obviously in Baker Farms he's a
fellow Trustee of the um
cobbled trust I've discussed that with
the legal representative and
I've advised him it's it's properly
declared but I don't think it
disqualifies him
thank you very much anyone else
no okay thank you the next item is
decorations of personal site visits do
we have any
thank you
um the next item is the minutes
confirmation of the minutes the meeting
held on the 7th December 22. there are
there any points regarding accuracy of
the minutes
nope could I have a proposal then for
them please Council Passmore and a
second uh thank you that's a mayor okay
so we'll now ask the governance officer
to conduct electronic vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
field
here
thank you chair
Council of War boys are you able to vote
online or would you like me to take your
vote verbally
you're abstaining okay thank you
thank you members chair that's um six
notes for one abstention that's carried
thank you very much
thank you very much I'll sign those
after the meeting okay agenda item
number six is to receive any
notification of petitions and coins with
the council's petitions are there any no
receipt yeah okay thank you so move
straight into the first planning
application before us today that's
dc2102956 land east of Warren Lane and
west of Crest Meadow Way in elmsworld
we'll hand over to the case officer to
first of all to Gemma Walker is going to
take us through this thank you
thank you chair
um yep so a land Easter foreign Lane and
west of Chris by the way and Elm swallow
said this is outlined for 44 dwellings
including the access with all other
matters reserved just to bring to
members attention that the
um constraints map has been updated
unfortunately the incorrect one is in
the back of the papers but I have got
the corrected one
um on the presentation and if we need a
paper copy for anybody we can share that
around as need to be
um also by way of an update just to note
that in places the neighborhood plan is
is reference but so it has been moving
on over the time that this application
has been in progress so to say that it's
now at between stages three and four
um but I've confirmed with the
neighborhood plan officer that it
continues to have limited weight at this
time
but there we go
no we're having sound troubles
snap
you don't need to speak into the
microphone it catches the whole area
okay well we'll do what we can but it's
as loud as it can go
see if that helps with Olivia
um so just to repeat that so the um the
neighborhood plan has moved on during
the time of this application
um but it confirmed with the
neighborhood planning officer that
although between stages three and four
now it still has limited weight at this
time
um previous committee members might
recognize this following prior deferrals
and what we're now looking up is a risk
assessment and an updated recommendation
provided and I will run through that
history but just to run through some of
the background and the PowerPoint first
for members so we've got a red line site
plan on screen
um
and we'll run through some of the
Aerials as well there we go so now I can
see that with the surrounding area and
almador to the north
and again just zooming out slightly as
you can see it in the wider context
and then a zoomed in version so we'll
look at the northern part of the site
and then the southern part of the site
coming down south towards the wooded
area
so the southern boundary comes down
approximately there but as we've seen in
the red line site plan
and again the constraints match so this
is the one that was not quite correct in
the bundle the um one of the bundle
suggests that the site only comes down
approximately that far and that was uh
similar to the previous
decision but we're now looking at an
application that comes further to the
South essentially um adjoining the
wooded area that we've seen in the
aerial photos
so what a site layout plan
showing that so we can see the wooded
area and then the edge of the site with
some landscaping and up here the
northernmost area we saw on the Aerials
as well
oh okay
um and the associated Landscaping plan
and then looking through at some more
errors and some photos here so again we
can see this was the original site on
previous consent and looking down with
how come this bit further sale
some views through so you can see this
is the way looking from the site through
and similarly if I get to work there we
go we're looking again from the site
through towards um or alone
and then again
some further views or we can see where
we are looking North up through the site
and again we're now looking up from the
site through to this corner
and then just a further back view
essentially so we can see the edge of
the wooded area here and the edge of
what's currently onto our just on the
ridge
and it's just a slightly closer view of
that
so the site does sit behind the trees
when we are looking from the east to
west and then we can see the on screen
the northern part being an infield in
that Gap essentially
and then we're looking
across the site here
and then we're looking down
across with the site to our left area in
front
and again site to our right here
and down through hopefully this is
familiar because there was a tight visit
back in May last year
run through if anybody wants to see
anything particular I'm happy to go back
of course
so again we're on the site here looking
up
so um as mentioned this had come to
committee previously the scheme
um was originally presented back in
December 2021 and the recommendations
still there on page 41 and it was
recommended for approval it was then
deferred for consideration of the impact
on the Quarry and then returned to
committee on the 9th of March 2022 and
that's the report recommendation Pages
23 to 26 and that confirms that it The
Proposal wouldn't Prejudice the Quarry
and it would be for any future
application to expand the Quarry to
consider the amenity of residents at
that time
following this the committee requested a
risk assessment for grounds of refusal
on traffic on the intrusion of the
development area and housing into the
countryside again with respect to the
Quarry and the housing land Supply
position along with the site visit which
as mentioned was undertaken in May last
year
with regards to the Quarry this is not
considered to be something that we would
support as a ground for refusal as the
previous committee the SEC minerals
consider that the housing won't
Prejudice the operation and that any
future application to expand the Quarry
will have to consider residents so we're
not suggesting that would be a a reason
that members would wish to carry forward
however we do agree that harm is
identified from intrusion into the
countryside and traffic concerns
also the housing land Supply position
has changed significantly over the
course of this application
the previous consent has expired and in
light of this progression through the
council's housing land Supply it's now
considered that the basket of policies
is up to date this wasn't the case when
the application first came to committee
we were considering those policies to be
out of date so that's the the change
that's particularly happened in the
meantime
so whilst there are some benefits from
this proposal in terms of the strands of
sustainability thinking of the provision
of housing including affordable housing
and from construction this is minor
particularly having regard to that how
strong housing land Supply position
noting that we're weighing in harm from
landscape and from concerns about the
risk to pedestrian safety from any
residents walking southwards
um
is such that the proposal isn't
considered to fulfill the requirements
of sustainable development and would we
contrary to the requirements of cs1 and
CS2 and for those reasons we're looking
now to recommend refusal following that
risk assessment and that's set out on
page 22. thank you chair
thank you
um so can we've got questions can I just
ask the first one so obviously this has
been to us before
um and members uh were particularly
focused at the time around the items you
say but also the impact of the Quarry so
are you saying that is not a
consideration for us today or it is with
limited weight what we are saying is
that it wouldn't be a a justifiable
reason for refusal we understand the
concerns but we've Revisited them twice
and been through those in a fair amount
of detail including with County minerals
and they advise that that's not a
concern from their side and we don't
think it's something that would justify
a reason for refusal from our sides
okay thank you I have to take questions
cancer possible and cancer string and
thanks Matthew
um good morning everyone uh because we
had a select visit I don't know how many
members went but that was very
informative and I certainly can't see
that the impact of the Quarry
um would be a reason for refusal I was
surprised how far it actually was when
you go and see the site what I'd like to
know please
um Jimmy you talked about the extra or
the 10-year land Supply we've got can
you explain how that really affects this
application please yeah of course of
course so um at a time when we don't
have a land Supply our policies are
therefore going to be out of date so we
can't use them and we're down to mppf
sustainability is it or is it not
sustainable and that's the position so
we're not using cs1 CS2 and various
other policies since then our housing
land Supply position has gone from
strength to strength um I can't remember
the exact figure but we're now currently
over 10 years so we're saying we have
significantly boosted the supply of
housing land and that is sufficient for
us to decide that our policies
particularly thinking cs1 and CS2 are up
to date
they are
then have to be considered with their
compliance to the mppf now what you
cannot do is apply them in a fashion
whereby inside the line is okay and
outside the line is not okay we still
have to have sustainability as a
consideration
and what we would say is in a key
service center or a town they are more
sustainable locations so it might not be
inside the line but nonetheless it would
be a sustainable location so there is a
balance between cs1 and CS2 being up to
date and some sustainable considerations
and that's what we're saying in this
case so cs1 and CS2 are up to date we've
got a land Supply that doesn't make them
out of date they are relatively
compliant with the mppf requirements and
the bits that this application breaches
of cs1 and CS2 are the bits that are up
to date and that the harm resulting so
we're not thinking any benefit
does that
and could I just have supplementary very
quickly
does this um whether we would this area
is it included within our 10-year land
Supply or not
this application the prior consent had
expired so that wouldn't have been
included I don't believe it's allocated
but I would have to triple check that
that's a Stringer yeah thank you uh
being one of the also one of the county
councilors that bounds this Quarry I
have to say I'm amazed at the response
from the minerals team given there
another three complaints okay sorry it's
not now it's not it's just questions for
clarity
no I I say I I was amazed at the
response did they not give you any idea
of the outstanding level of complaint
from the existing residents in this area
recently so it's been through other
offices in the meantime but not from the
update that I have had that they weren't
raising objection on that
easy
Council field
the concern about pedestrians on Warren
Lane is it one
um the road to the South
I think the second application is the
other end of that road I was just
wondering what are the attractions down
there that we feel
so significant clearly the village of in
the whole village if you like exists and
people could walk down this road to
whatever the attractions are why is it
so important for this relative
I might actually invite Danny on that
one to you probably can list all of the
different companies down there at being
your site but there are a variety out
there so
um the current application current
family was for Truck East to go not drop
East I've got the wrong one um
sorry let's put the microphone so
present on the lawn Farm Business Park
site we have pre-con products we are
backed in transport and we have Truck
East and we have another application on
the agenda before members for
consideration later that would bring
another user onto that site
so there's a cluster of employment
allocation employment sites down there
that are local and it's quite a big
cluster so it's not just people
wandering down to the cafe for coffee is
employment use that's
Castleman so we have a question
um well I I wanted just to check that we
had done um uh decorations of lobbying
um I'm sorry if we missed it but I got
an email from the agent about this
application and I believe it was sent to
everybody
foreign
in the rush
um with our late start so let's just
pick that up now decorations of lobbying
can we just have a quick show of hands
yeah on this item thank you
and am I allowed to answer about the
question that's just been asked or do
you want me to put that in my my speech
about all of the things that I've done
in your speech in the other direction
because I put it in your speech
thanks let's put any other questions for
clarity yep councilman
it may be my memory that's letting me
down
but when this previously came before
committee
you were recommending approval
the land Supply hasn't changed since
then dramatically
the Quarry is not an issue
so why the fundamental change in your
position what is driving that
um so it's a combination I think in the
original recommendation we had given
weight to the
um
prettiest consent that's not expired so
we've got no weight to give to that so
I've got no concern the land supply has
boosted although we had a land Supply
there was a time in which you you still
need to continue it's not a cap but it
doesn't limit our consent and we've got
to keep going but I think it's now been
recognized and appealed that having got
10 years is now so significant that
actually yeah so it's just it sways in
that balance in that way
thank you
no other questions we'll move on okay
thank you um so next uh are now uh hear
from members of the public first up is
the parish council we have Peter Dao if
you'd like to talk to the mic and if you
remember that you have three minutes
do ask you to keep to that please
there is a timer up here
thank you chairman I've been asked to
encourage members to back their officer
in recommending refusal of this
application
the community accepted the original
proposal in 2018 for 38 dwellings within
the development envelope at this
visually sensitive most southerly
boundary of the village however it made
vigorous protests of the suggestion that
this site should be permitted to expand
into the countryside
the approach of Warren Lane East Village
is resolutely rural a single Track Road
with informal passing places eaten into
the bank
The View undulates as you drive uphill
to approach the village with a clear
delineation as to where the countryside
ends and ellsworld starts
we make few claims to be a pretty
Village we're well aware of the
realities of development pressure and
have accepted with reasonably good Grace
A Generous proportion of housing
development in the district
in this instance we are asked to not
only accept the original 38 houses
linked to the 240 on whetherton road but
to agree to a total of 44 houses by
allowing a significant and damaging
incursion into the countryside
we suggest that there must be
exceptional factors if this proposal is
to be allowed to breach policy and
introduce development creep beyond our
village southern boundary such factors
might include the Improvement offered to
the Quality character or appearance of
the area
we argue that the opposite is the case
and that it would impact detrimentally
on this key landscape on a main approach
to the Village or it might be suggested
that elsil needs more houses and that
the need is so desperate as to support
the abrogation of the relevant planning
policy and guidance
the reason that elmsl has taken a
substantial element of development in
the district and consequently has a very
adequate range of housing both
established and emerging
other factors commonly introduced regard
are contribution to the economy and the
Vitality of our community these ring
Hollow when account is taken of the
solid community base which The Village
fights to support and maintain and
improve without the imposition and
strains of unjustified ad hoc
developments such as this
I asked members to agree with the
officer's view that this proposal fails
to fulfill the requirements of
sustainable development that the harms
identified would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh any suggested
benefits and that they authorize refusal
of the permission
thank you very much any questions
no okay oh yes cancer Stringer now just
looking up the submission into the
course the into the joint local plan and
and it does show part of this site as an
allocation in the joint local plan is
part of this site due to be an
allocation in your neighborhood plan the
neighborhood plan includes the site
which effectively was the first 38
houses
okay thank you very much
um so we'll now move on
so we've got
um no objector no supporter but we have
the agent James Bailey with Jamie Martin
Edwards the agent and Bill Barker the
applicant to take questions and over to
you and again three minutes please
good morning chair members we're here
again to discuss the site of Warren Lane
mswell and I'm joined this morning by
the applicant and landowner Bill Baker
and also Jamie Martin Edwards from our
planning consultancy it's disappointing
that we find ourselves in this situation
for sites that previously had a planning
permission has long been identified in
the emerging local plan and is more
recently being included within the
amswell neighborhood plan on the
previous two planning committees there
were officer recommendations for
approval and it was even proposed and uh
for approval and seconded at the
December committee members openly stated
that they thought the proposal
represented a much better scheme with an
improved layout and a much lower density
therefore following the request for a
risk assessment it has come as a
surprise and a disappointment that our
new planning officer has reached a
different conclusion that said this is
the nature of planning there are no
definitive or clear-cut answers and
planners can assess schemes benefits and
policies differently and they can come
to varying conclusions as your officer
suggests in their report any waiting on
these matters is subjective with the
owners being on the decision maker you
as the members it will therefore come as
no surprise that we strongly differ in
our findings of the council's risk
assessment particularly with reference
to highways encroachment and Landscape
the Quarry expansion site was confirmed
as not being an issue for this proposal
by Suffolk County Council back in
January of last year independent advice
was sought on Landscaping matters at the
taxpayers expense which reached the same
conclusion that any landscape arm would
not outweigh the landscape benefits from
this proposal an SCC highways have
continued to reiterate that there are no
highways issues or concerns with this
residential proposal they do not have an
issue with pedestrian safety and for all
intents and purposes Warren Lane could
be classified as a quiet Lane these
would all represent genuine risks for
the council at any future appeal the
council's housing land Supply is noted
however the nppf continues to State
these figures should be treated as a
floor and not a ceiling I believe it's
all slightly disingenuous of your
offices to suggest there are any modest
benefits with this scheme we are happy
for the layout to be conditioned which
will fix the proposals you see in terms
of housing mix and layouts they would
gen they would guarantee the delivery of
35 affordable housing and the delivery
of nine Bungalows footpath connections
were proposed that were linked to the
village and members were encouraged by
The Pedestrian connections at the site
visit additional passing places will be
introduced along Warren Lane along with
physical safety improvements to Warren
Lane Church Road and the cross street
Junction for all users to benefit from
Landscaping open space and suitable
subsystems will be provided which are
accepted as biodiversity benefits and
there will also be Financial
contributions towards local education as
well as a contribution towards adamswell
and woolpit's footpath and cycleway
project the question therefore before
members today should be quite simple is
this a better scheme than members
previously approved are there genuine
local benefits being provided and does
six dwellings above the 38 previously
permitted undermine or add to the
council's local uh land supply thank you
very much
thank you okay do we have any questions
yes
if we start over that Council mayor
first
in the original application was it up to
38 Properties or was it a definite 38
properties
there's 38 properties on the 38
dwellings
so
what you've just said then
is it your premise that by extending
this site beyond the original boundary
you are improving the delivery of the
site
the quality
yes if I can expand on that if that's
okay Jim
effectively what we've got is a scheme
that now does go further into the
countryside that is accepted it's
physically accepted by the the lines on
the plan that we've seen this morning
however what it has enabled is a
different scheme to be proposed one that
goes into far more detailed and was
actually originally granted back in 2018
that includes a definitive number of
types of houses the likes of Bungalows
that we know have been required uh over
the recent years but also the types of
systems that are being provided in terms
of the subsystems much of which is going
to be over land and also improved
footpath connections that wasn't exactly
uh proposed previously these things have
all come about through positive
discussions over the last couple of
years with your offices to make
admittedly a slightly larger scheme a
slightly larger in in terms of numbers
and space but actually a better scheme
overall and that includes a much lower
density as well reducing it I believe
down from 20 trainings per hectare to
just over 15 dwellings per hectare okay
thank
you thank you thanks I may have missed
this but could you just help me if we
got um 44 dwellings what are the actual
numbers for the mix I know we've got
Bungalows affordable housing but what is
the other spread so forgive me if I
didn't pick that up
no problem at all what we've got
um and again I would uh would have to
have a quick look through the actual
accommodation schedule so I do apologize
but this is sets are on on our proposed
layout plan if that was to be approved
as an approved document the schedule
that he set out on there which includes
the number of affordable houses the type
of affordable houses and the number of
Bungalows this could be guaranteed and
this would then be worked forward
through any reserved matters so what
we've got uh in terms of the scheduled
summary just so that I can read that out
for everybody is uh 44 units as a total
uh there are four one-bedroom
departments there are two uh there are
four uh two-bedroomed bungalows
there are four two-bedroomed houses so
clearly those different sorts there are
five three bedroomed Bungalows there are
eighteen three bedroomed houses and
there are nine four bedroomed houses
that's the makeup that has been provided
and has been drawn on the layout in
front of you
Jimmy you wanted to come in
say the
the patient 4909 of 16 does say up to 38
dwellings that is in the papers is from
our system
yeah Council stranger just wanted to
bottom out the improved footpath link
ing on plan for on page 45 I've tried to
draw where the
existed where the proposed settlement
boundary in the jlp enabled the planar I
can see one near the suds at e where it
goes into Crest Meadow Way
the only other footpath link I can see
that isn't linking the houses in the
extent in beyond that boundary is point
e far right on that far bottom of that
page
does that link into a public
right-of-way
yes it does and if I can cancel the
string I think there are there are three
point E's if you like on on the plan
there is one uh furthest over towards uh
the uh the left-hand side of the plan
which links uh towards the gray area
thinking towards Warren Lane to the top
yeah uh there is the area going towards
uh Crest Meadow Way which again would
link into the footpath there and again
the uh the final e is towards the bottom
of the plan uh which uh again uh links
into
um I believe it's an informal footpath
on there so this would formalize all of
these areas and it sorry I asked if it
was a right of way an informal
so so what does that link to
speaking there it's a permissive
brighter way I understand
okay
so that that could that could go at any
moment then
yeah if if I can that that's exactly the
the point that this would uh start to
formalize that through through this
scheme
uh any other questions before we move on
okay so we'll move on to the ward
members we have two board members uh
here we have Council geek and councilman
so should I read out councilor Geeks
first or do you want to go further
okay first yeah yeah so here's from
Council geek who apologizes she couldn't
be here today
I support the officer's recommendation
that the application should be refused
on the grounds of dangerous traffic and
intrusion into the countryside given
that we have a housing land Supply in
excess of five years
the location of the Southern edge of the
proposed development so close to the
Quarry should also be a cause for
legitimate concern
as the previous consent for the smaller
site has expired and the recent appeal
decisions have changed the policy
background since the consent was granted
I support the officer's view that there
are few benefits to outweigh these
problems
over to you
thank you I too support the officer
recommendation for refusal on this
application the extension of the site
into the countryside purely to provide
uh the so-called improved layout and six
more dwellings
um is insufficient to outweigh any
benefits
there's nothing stopping the applicant
from proposing fewer than the T8
dwellings to make his make an approve
improved or better layout within the
existing plot that's already got the
extent planning permission we also hear
that it's of a lower density but does
that mean it's better we actually need
more smaller dwellings
um uh for first-time buyers and the like
and low identity usually means that the
houses end up being bigger
um for information of facilities to the
South along Warren Lane as well as the
employment site at lawn Farm which we'll
go into in the next application
um there is a neighboring site which is
forever expanding with a a load of
planning applications fairly regularly
we have the Stag Cafe and Asian
restaurant a butcher and I'm sure
there'll be yet more to come because
there's no no formal plan for that site
I have always considered that the access
to this site is very contrived
um go having to go down the single track
Warren Lane to provide access all the
way around the back ideally
um access should be closer to the center
of the village anyway via crestmeadow
way now this is actually a private road
and the residents are not particularly
happy about even pedestrian and cycle
access onto crestmeadow way and should
this be approved that pedestrian cycle
access does need to be secured because
we don't want uh pedestrians and and
cyclists having to go around the long
way
um the previous outline application for
the 38 houses was submitted in parallel
with another application for 240 homes
on weatherden road
um and I believe there was as well as
the highway improvements for the
crossroads and the um passing places on
Warren Lane there was also a lot of
discussion about improving that
pedestrian public footpath network from
the open space behind the wetherden road
application site
the link to the South The Pedestrian
Access Link that's shown on the map that
was questioned by Council Stringer that
is not a public footpath that is only a
permissive path
um and it should should this go ahead
um you know there doesn't seem to be any
plan for formalizing that to be a become
a proper public footpath
as you say it could stop
um Warren Lane is a narrow road there is
a lot of traffic on it um there are a
few
um passing places that were created a
few years ago but they're not really
used properly traffic just passes
wherever it meets and there's an awful
lot of erosion of The Verge and the
fields beside it uh the Quarry is a
cause for concern there are numerous
complaints on a regular basis about the
operation as it stands now and should it
be expanding one can only assume that
those might improve increase
um
uh so you know I support the officer
um recommendation for refusal and I hope
that the committee will go along with
that thank you
thanks very much any questions
so members we've had all the information
put before us that's now up to us to
discuss and debate and come to a
conclusion
councilor Stringer you want to start off
I didn't want to come in uh being a
interloper on this committee for this
one but you're all being shy
um yeah uh I I don't have a huge problem
with coming to a decision on this I I
think the officer's recommendation
is is has been
on balance about right we have a plan
LED approach
every plan that we see
has housing in this application going
over that plan's boundary to deliver
what is claimed to be a sustainable
pattern of development
what what we haven't seen uh and it is
is is is a plan derived inside of that
line uh that could be a higher density I
mean lower densities are not necessarily
by themselves a good thing it could you
could read lower previous governments of
of and planning documents and
suggestions at lower density was an
inefficient use of land and given
there's extra land owned by the
applicant there could be a scheme within
that red line that's a higher density
within policy
within bounds of the joint upcoming
joint local plan the emerging
neighborhood plan and our existing
policies that could deliver this site
sustainably
and and it's it's trying to balance the
the
the pluses against the minuses the minus
is going outside of what is the planned
approach
and the plus is
well there's there's a maybe a footpath
that links the houses that have gone
outside of that plan uh and it's allowed
them a bit more space to put some some
Greenery in among the development I I
personally don't think that's a price
worth paying to go outside of those uh
existing plans uh and and I feel they
could there could easily be a solution
here that's within all of those plan
policies and those planned boundaries so
for I I certainly would agree with the
officer recommendation I've deliberately
not mentioned the issues surrounding the
Quarry but I will be taking that up in
other way because there are issues with
the Quarry that affect residential
immunity that have not been flagged up
to this committee and should have done
uh we should have been informed about
the outstanding complaints about noise
light and pollution from from the
existing Quarry because if that extends
that is going to come to the these
people's doors as well as the existing
peoples but I I won't use that in in any
of the policy recommendations that I'm
looking at today but I would be
perfectly happy to move refusal along
the lines of the officer recommendation
thank you
customer yeah um I'd like to make you
comments made by my colleague I
struggle to see why
the improved layout should carry the day
is that sufficient it's an improved
layout because more work's being done on
it it's an improved layout
perhaps because it does have
um
less density but as my colleague says
that may or may not be a good thing
but the smaller layout could be improved
don't see enough here to justify going
beyond the outline the the
the
lines that are drawn in the existing
plans so I am quite happy to Second The
Proposal
for accepting the officer's
recommendation thank you councilman
thank you Matthew well
um this is a particularly difficult one
and I have to say
um the site visit we had back in the
summer was actually very very useful
um and the distance between the Quarry
and I know that's not what we're looking
at I do think is worthy of note there so
I'm not entirely convinced that that is
would cause a great deal of harm in that
development but I do accept what the
world member and others have said and I
also do like the housing mix within this
and I understand where the offices are
coming from and the change in approach
here
um but I'm I'm I shall listen to what
others say before before I decide on
this I just wanted to make those views
clear that housing mix I think is quite
valuable for us in in mid-suffolk um
particularly the smaller accommodation
Bungalows and some we do need more of
those
um so I hear what other people have got
to say and I've certainly know about the
land Supply we've got there which I
think you put in the report is nearly 11
years actually it's nearer to 11 rather
than 10. um
so um I'm for once very very unusually
rather sitting on the fence
I want myself counselor field
cheer
I need that iPhone wind
many of the arguments against this site
of
being disproved to my own certainly
various
authorities for instance highways have
suggested that the concerns are not
valid
so in earlier occasions I've been in
favor of this development
of to say
it does include the encroach into the
countryside
for the sake of a small you know a half
dozen or so houses
and we do have an 11-year land Supply we
we have got more than sufficient in the
pipeline
so to me that questions the the need for
that Countryside Excursion
at the moment I'm feeling that I am not
going to support this application
thanks very much
um everyone yes Castle War boys you want
to go they're not coming after you
think I've got to come thank Council
feel is is actually giving me a clue
into this it's the actual six additional
houses for me that that actually sort of
um
bring forward the points the um case
offers made uh those additional six
houses increased the risk of pedestrians
along
um Warren Road uh they further extend
into open Countryside and it's balancing
that harm I think against the
um
economic benefits so I found that
Council feel it it it's the original 38
hours old in the um
local plan the neighborhood plan
um and it was that I think it's that
increase for me which actually really
proves the case officers
comments so I I find I am supporting
what the case officer said to
uh not to approve this application
thank you and I'm also going to support
the officer's recommendation I think the
landscape's changed since it came to us
before uh which uh and I understand why
in the case obviously explain the
reasons why
um I can imagine that the applicant is
probably quite frustrated that there's
been that change and I recognize that
but that's why there is an appeals
process where actually if we refuse it
if the applicant feels that's not right
they do have the right obviously to go
to the planning inspector to look at
this so for me I'm comfortable with the
recommendation I can see how the
Journey's changed and why the landscape
has changed that's brought us to that
which is different than before so I'll
also be supporting that recommendation
everyone's spoken that's been proposed
by councilor Stringer and second of our
councilor mayor that we support the
officer's recommendation so I'll now
hand over to the um governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress uh
councilor field can I take your vote
please
so that's a full refusal thank you
thank you members that is five votes
four refusalem one against chairs so
that's Carrie to thank you thank you
very much
okay so we'll move on to the next
application for us today which is um
dc2204002
land Lawn Park Business Center Warren
Lane woolpit are now hand over to the
case of the Daniel Cameron to introduce
the application to committee
thank you chair so before we start
processing through uh the presentation I
just wanted to make clear for members
the scope of the application we had
before us it's what's known as a hybrid
application so we have one part made in
full so if we may incision to approve
that part of the application could
commence construction as soon as they're
able we have one part made an outline
such that that part would be subject to
a further Reserve matters application
and that would come back before members
for consideration when that's made the
way that the decision notice would
operate on that one is that we would
split
um the decision notice we make clear
that one part of conditions would apply
only to that application granted in full
and one part would apply only to that
application granted in outline and those
have been set up for you in the
recommendation
at the end of the report
so what we have is we have the lawn Farm
Business Park and we have plots four and
five on that site coming forward for a
B8 storage use with the class EG office
and we also have an outline for plot six
with flexible EG office B2 like
industrial or B8 used to come forward at
a future date
members will know we're not too far away
from the site previously considered in
the previous item
our aerial mapping shows the extent of
the hybrid application here
um members will note that
in the expanded we have pre-com products
site here we have the bactin transport
site here and we have the new site for
Truck East
here to the West Warren Lane is
here to the north linking to Elms well
we'll pit is off to the west and hallium
Wellington are located to the East and
we can just see the edge of Hawley Park
in
desire
if we come to the constraints map
members will note we have three listed
buildings in particular lawn Farmhouse
and Lawn Cottage both grade two listed
and we also have one across the A14
um also grade two listed but for the
purposes of this application
the Heritage team feel that these are
the two most
important assets affected we've also on
the edge of a special landscape area
denoted by this area of dense Woodland
to the east our site is not within the
special landscape area but we are
immediately adjacent to it and we also
have a public right-of-way running
roughly north south
through the site and then under the A14
and out the other end
if we come a little bit further out you
can see the extent of that public
right-of-way
linking up onto all day 45 and then
coming down through and we can also see
part of the edge of Elsewhere as well
Just for information this is an image of
lawn Farmhouse the grade two listed
building
um
and then this is an image of the
business buildings at the scaffolding
business currently on site at lawn
Farmhouse operates out of
um to quickly run through the planning
history because I accept for members
there's a lot of planning history
involved in that section and you'll note
in an earlier section of the report I've
tried to slim that down so we're just
looking at
um what affects lawn Farm business park
so we have backed in transport and
pre-com products linked up in those pink
boxes at the north of the site we have
the new Truckee site
and we have the Star Cafe conglomeration
of buildings
within this triangle between the old A45
and the A14
this orange parcel was given uh
permission as part of the first DC
1802179 application on the site that
secured the pre-con backed in transport
buildings we then had outline up
permission granted on
the yellow and green Parcels of land
under DC
1803851 applications and then the blue
parts of land has no planning history on
it
um
and if we come forward onto our site
location plan
parcel 4 plot four is on that
um part of one that previously had
outline permission and plot five and six
are on those plots of land that had no
permission
available for them
if we come to this color plan the yellow
aspect of the site is what would be
covered by the full planning application
and the green part of the site would be
what's covered by the outline the plot
six is this small area bounded by the
A14 and at the edge of the site and
plots four and five with wrap
um
lawn farmhouse
Farm Cottage and the intervening
um so I'm in there
within plot four there's a proposal for
a small office building to oversee the
um storage use within that plot
um
the building would measure at highest
5.8 meters high and for reference
pre-con and backed in transport
buildings both measure 10 meters high
with regards to the height of external
storage within plots four and five that
will be capped at five meters above
ground level and similar dispensation is
given to pre-com products on the
neighboring site for external storage no
more five meters high
members will note from the console T
responses that we're still waiting for a
sign off from ecology and Landscaping I
had hoped to be in a position to give
you updated comments as late papers or
as verbal updates within this meeting at
present I have no written formal
comments from Play services ecology
although Sue who has reviewed the
district level licensing application
that has been submitted in regards to
the issue around Great Crested Newton
has said that that looks to be
sufficient but we'll wait for formal
comments
ecologist Who provided the initial
comments on the site before agreeing
that and with regards to Landscaping
it's understood that Landscaping
colleagues have been back out to site
this week to come to a decision as to
whether additional wireframe drawings
are required to support the lvia that's
already been submitted
and we'll have that in due course and
that is why the recommendation before
you members is not changed from the one
made in the report it's to delegate
Authority the chief planning officer
subject to
from ecology and Landscaping that all
matters are dealt with there and we
would have scope within that
recommendation to apply whatever
conditions ecology and Landscaping felt
were necessary in order in order to
bring the application forward
go forward here
um vehicle tracking for HIV movements
into and out of the site have been
provided and highways have no
way with the tracking of hdvs from
within the site in to it and then back
out with regards to plots four and five
additional tracking may be required in
respect of plot six when that comes
forward but that will form part of any
reserve matters application in any event
the access into the site that was agreed
as part of the DC
1801279 application is still for hdb
traffic into and out of the site and is
capable of taking the additional hdv
traffic flows
if we turn quickly to the Landscaping
plan
significant landscape buffers have been
provided around the edge of the buckton
transport site and the pre-com product
site that is currently establishing and
the application before us proposes to
continue that Landscaping buffer down
around the edge of the listed buildings
and then around within the site as well
to provide some additional screening to
the South and to the West
we also have the arbo or a cultural plan
here we've got um existing cat ABC and
new trees on this boundary around uh
lawn Farmhouse and Lawn Cottage only one
tree is proposed to be removed as a
result of these works and that is a
category u tree of no amenity value and
I think that is located just here where
that cursor is so well away from the
listed building so the existing
screening around the
as part of this application and then
strengthened as a result of the
Landscaping Works which we would have
your offices would have full detail over
um turning quickly to the Suffolk hdv
routing map this is the updated map as
live on their website the A14 is a
strategic group marked in red and all
Lorry routes through the county are
expected to utilize this where
appropriate
the green Mark here from Junction 47a
off the A14 down to Junction 48 is a
local access route so only Vehicles
making their departure from or
delivering two sites along this route
are permitted to utilize it
so any hgvs leaving the site would be
required to turn right out of the site
come up through holy New Street and then
make that connection to the A14 at
Junction 48 and on the upcoming traffic
moving to the east would be able to use
Junction 47a
we wouldn't have any traffic traveling
north along Warren Lane up into Elm as
well north south down Warren Lane Woods
Road it's not part of the route and then
we need to find alternative routes there
I could enter some photos this is the
edge of
lawn Farmhouse plot full looking South
within the site we've got the edge of
baton transport we've got pre-com
products Focus this afternoon you can
just Glimpse the edge of the new truck
East Building
further south the site is currently low
to grass and we've got that run of trees
existing along the edge of the lawn Farm
site just on the edge of the image
uh we now have the view from the site
further along Warren Lane you can
Glimpse the edge of the SLA with the
dense Woodland uh
Warren Lane continuing here and then we
have the edge of the pre-con
product site here
and then this is a view within the site
so this is at the edge of the current
site where that's working this new plots
of Harris fenced off we have that SLA
view in the in the background and we
have the planting around Along The
Farmhouse and Lawn Cottage and this is a
view of a plot 4 and plot five
and then this is a view
um across the site the attenuation Basin
be located off to the left of the image
and you can see the A40 14 running
um along the edge of this along the edge
of the image there
coming now to the view from a the A14
we've got the pre-con and Baton
um
sites in the distance and then if we
come slightly further north on the A14
you can get a view across uh plot 4 the
screening around lawn Farmhouse and Lawn
Cottage
plot five
we come now to the Views shown within
the Long View
landscape visual impact assessment
submitted as part of the application
this is from the edge of plot six
looking East within the site
we've got lawn Cottage
um here lawn Farmhouse here screened by
planting around and then the SLA dense
Woodland
off to the east the attenuation basis is
located in this area and then we have
existing buildings on Moon farm
we have uh this view further into the
site you can Glimpse the edge of lawn
Farmhouse as shown in the earlier images
the A14 running
along the edge of the site the
attenuation Base is located here
and if we then come to wool pit we can
see some views of the existing
um
uh Business Park
plot four and five
slide we have now we have one further on
from the south so we can see uh pre-con
and the the blue
kingspan panels on the edge
meshing well with the
with the summer sky behind but obviously
except members that we might have
something different here and we have the
SLA in the background there with regards
to Heritage impact
we have a level of less and substantial
harm
um the setting of lawn Farmhouse is
already dominated by the scaffolding
around it
an attention from Parish Council
comments with regards to previous
applications on the lawn Farm site to
bring forward Housing Development is
that that was refused due to its adverse
impact on the setting of the listed
building
within the report officers have looked
at that
inspectors report and those dwellings
would be located far closer on the other
side of the existing screening around
lawn Farmhouse
and given the business use already in
place and the impact on the setting that
makes the lawn farmer house your
heritage officers have recommended a low
level of less substantial harm and with
regard to the balancing as required by
the mppf officers consider that in
regards to the expansion of the site
which is part of the joint local plan
for employment allocation
it's recommended that the um
the balance in terms of the additional
full-time employment offered and other
benefits of the site are such that it's
acceptable in that regard I'll pass over
now to members for questions arising
from the report and I'll let you move on
to debate
thank you very much questions can I um
just ask a quick couple
um so on the parish council says that in
the past
find the page on page 49 on several
occasions applications and appeals for
five dwellings on the farmyard site and
the scaffolding site have been refused
because of their closeness to the listed
buildings
so could you just explain if that is the
case why Heritage think that that's not
acceptable but this is just so we can
have some clarity on that point please
of course chair so that wasn't the only
reason
um
those applications refused it was in
part on their impact on the setting of
the listed building but was also in part
given their remoteness from elsewhere
walpit Hawley and wetherden and the fact
that
um any residential dwellings there would
be heavily reliant on the private motor
vehicle in order to make their
you know connections to those services
and Facilities within those Villages
um
the other issue is that the Lawn Park
site the housing included conversion of
the barn that we saw in the images
earlier in the report and the erection
of five dwellings within the grounds of
the law and Farmhouse site
um
this site is separated from lawn
Farmhouse
we have the existing Landscaping there
we have the additionality of additional
Landscaping so that lawn Farmhouse
wouldn't be seen in conjunction with
um this application we also have the
benefits of
um the additional employment use on it
on a designated on a site that will be
designated within the jlp
um once part one comes forward that's
part of our strategic allocations
um and also then the associate benefits
therein
can we just go to a map of on our on our
papers it's page 721 it just shows the
access in and out of the site
the main access yeah it's just the
general access so what I'm just
interested in is from from the uh one
more one more keep going I think this
might be the best yeah so can you just
explain the access in and out of the
site
uh for the vehicles just so we're really
clear yeah so we have
um an access on to the old
um A45 here at this point this was
brought in as part of the original
application that brought forward the
pre-con and backed in transport onto the
site
um both users
um
utilize hdv vehicles for their business
movements
um this access it's a nice wide access
highways are content that there is
sufficient scope within the construction
of the access to take the additional hdv
movements that would be created by plots
four and five and then with regards to
plot six that those movements will be
assessed at the time of the reserve
matters once we had further Clarity on
whether that's to be an EG office
movement or EG Office business
um
a light industrial business or a storage
use each of those will probably have
very different needs with regards to hgv
movements and other vehicle movements
that will be associated with road access
to that point that you said is a nice
wide opening and we've got a map that
can show us how you get to point
because that's what we've had lots of
comments on
so the aerial might be useful but if I
if I come to the the HTV routing
yeah have you got on page 71 of our
papers have you got that
picture
stop me when I'm on 875 but yeah of
course we can we can bring that forward
no yeah
there you go so so can you just be clear
from there just take us through access
to the site okay so um hgv Vehicles
traveling East along the A14 can make
their access at Junction 47a off the A14
so this would be on to the local route
they then travel up the a
um 45 and make their access in this
point
with the existing access here anything
traveling westbound along the A14 would
need to make their access at Junction
48.
and then come along holy new road to be
able to come down the old A45 to make
their access in here there's no scope
within the Suffolk hgv routing map to
make an alternative approach so you
wouldn't be able to come in through
elmsworld you won't be able to come in
when you say you wouldn't be able to
well could you explain if if you were
making a proper route utilizing the
Suffolk hdv routing Network
you should not be able to
the
the reality is that
if there was an HIV driver that was
unfamiliar with the site
they might well do so but I suspect
given that we have two existing hdv
users on the site already there's
already clear routing instructions for
those users that could be ported across
to this operator and I'm sure we
probably have no issue and the agent can
confirm for me requiring hdv routing in
accordance with the Suffolk hdv routing
plan to all hevs into the site and out
of the site could then be dealt with and
we could have a clear
um requirement that should any
um
issues be noted arising from this
operator there would probably be scope
within their agreement with the site
owner to
take remedial action to ensure that
doesn't happen in future thank you yes
Castle
thanks uh we've just got a couple of
questions first one given the protracted
I'd almost call it Litany of um
applications of this site I see it says
here that development to start if it's
given within three years
what is what what in your view
constitutes the start of the development
because what we I'm just thinking about
we don't want to keep going through this
process that's the reason behind my
question
so with regards to commencement that sat
out within the Town and Country planning
order
sorry 1990 as men dude okay um so it
would need to be a legal commencement in
accordance with the works as set out
there so that can be
um a wide variety of things I would
suspect for this site the act that would
create the commencement be the creation
of the hgv access into the site and the
laying of the access but it could also
be provision of the drainage
um into the attenuation Basin within the
site
of utilities as part of foundation
so it wouldn't be just someone getting a
back action digging a six foot trench
and then leaving and being a little bit
flippant there well it can be the the
actors allow that um but I would Suspect
with development of this scale yeah
we want to get it right thanks and the
other question I want to ask the
Landscaping it is a sensitive site
are you and I'm not trying to put you in
an awkward position here confident that
it really will be a landscaping scheme
that is fit for purpose so I'm trying to
get at here
can it be a really enhanced Landscaping
scheme because it is a sensitive site
we've heard all sorts of issues and not
just a token a few hedge plants I'm not
saying that is what it is but how could
we really ensure that it is a top of the
notch if it goes ahead no no that's a
good Landscaping scheme that
fit for purpose so at the moment
um a query has been made to place
Landscaping to say your comments require
a wireframe assessment
for clarity do they mean that to relate
to the open storage areas or do they
mean that to relate to the office
building solely so that's what they're
going out to go and double check
um
and then come forward with I think we
can secure a landscaping scheme that
would be sufficient for the site we've
secured it previously with regards to
the pre-com product site and back to the
transport site and the Truckee site so
there's no
there's no issue with that
um and when we conducted the the
pre-application site with the
um owner they were very keen to see
additional tree planting on the site
um it was not a day on land on the other
side of the A14 that they're conducting
tree planting on as well so it would
just be a case of getting the detail
right for them and then allowing them to
get on and Implement that in a
proper manner
councilman Merlin Council field
um
I'm just pointed not to see a comment
from the Heritage team we work in a
plan-led system and yet we've been asked
to accept comments made during informal
pre-discussions so my question is to Mr
Dupre
is that good enough
this is you know is this not hearsay you
know the Heritage team had a chat at the
coffee machine and said that it's um
less than substantial harm but haven't
made a comment when
previous applications have been rejected
on appeal for partially Heritage reasons
well I mean chairman the the officers
it's worth and made his report she was
perfectly proper that you query and and
I
and question and I
think the officer will do his best to
comment further if it's appropriate
it was a formal pre-application inquiry
that was undertaken so we did have the
benefit of Heritage officer making a
site visit and we do have their written
comments from
um
from the time of the the pre-application
response
um with regard to their comments on the
site
um
as reported in the in the in the report
that's before you members their comments
were
low level of less and substantial harm
and that's what we've taken forward here
there's very minimal change between what
was brought forward at
um pre-application inquiry stage and
what's before is here
um it was always for
um full on plots four and five with
additional Landscaping acoustic barriers
Etc to be put up to create that boundary
between this site and Lawn Farmhouse and
Lawn Cottage
um so in that in that respect the
comments
um are held to be reflective of what's
before you hear members
um the issue that we generally have here
and it's probably something that we've
made comment on with regards to
um
other applications that our heritage
team haven't provided as up-to-date
comments for and we are reliant on their
pre-application comments for is that
those those are the comments that we
have we can ask them for the responses
disappointing that we don't always get a
full
um response for members to have that
that Clarity on that issue for
um
but we do have their their
pre-application comments and in this in
this instance my view is that because
that has been so little change that
their comments would still apply in
regards to this application but members
may wish to take a different View and if
that's either numbers take so it is
seems straight in your opinion and I
think Mr chairman I think he's the
officer's been put in an individious
position it would have taken very little
effort for the Heritage team to say that
my comments have not changed since pre
uh discussion um they haven't done so
and I think they've put the officer in a
very difficult position
especially with the history of the site
uh councilor field
thank you just a couple of points uh one
there's quite a passionate letter from
the uh owner of long form about
disturbance uh you know impact on their
immunity
um
what have we done about that I mean are
we totally convinced that the um
acoustic fencing is going to be an
adequate preventer of that sort of
disturbance or rejection
second point is that um this is another
development in the countryside and we've
just rejected one that's within us
Stone side probably if you're good with
a stone it is
um
are close by sites that says
for housing that we have a 10-year
Supply and therefore we don't want to
see excuses and it encouraging into the
countries
excuse me
excuse me um
is there an equivalent for this this is
an employment side clearly which is
different do we have a record of how
we're doing with employment land that we
could so we we have a lack and therefore
this is essential we have a circuit and
therefore this isn't uh
isn't vital at all okay in terms of um
impacts on light and noise pollution our
environmental health Team consider the
subject to conditions
um the impacts of noise and light should
be made acceptable
um with regard to noise that includes
agreeing hours of work hours of noisy
work
um creation of the acoustic fence as
required by the acoustic report
um
so we've we've put those conditions in
and we've put similar conditions in the
outline with regards to lighting and
noise as well so we have those details
to consider concurrent with the reserve
matters so that when we get that forward
we know what those impacts are going to
be and we can address those when the
reserve matters comes before us with
regard to
employment land Supply
I would suggest we maybe don't look too
deeply into that councils generally
struggle with
meeting there
require targets and there are quite
often
appeals where councils look to protect
employment land when they there isn't a
record of in
Employment Development coming forward to
take up that land
I will have a little look through our
system and see if I can find something
in the annual monitoring port for you
and I can report back later in debate
um
in general with regards to the location
of the application site it's adjacent to
an existing business use
it's coming forward as part of strategic
policy sp5 which would form part of the
the first part of the joint local plan
as I understand it
such that
we would be giving an employment
um use to that site more generally in
the future
um but I think when we look at policy
cs1 and CS2 yes we are outside the
settler boundary yes we are in the
countryside
um but if we have regards to the mppf
and the age of the policies contained
within the development plan with regards
to employment policies
um paragraph 84 in
um
section 3.5 of the report says that we
should be supporting sustainable growth
of
businesses even located in rural areas
um and paragraph 85 says that to meet
those needs we may have to find sites
outside of the settlement boundary
they're not well served by public
transport so I think if we were looking
to um
pose the application on that basis we
need to be able to demonstrate
what the what the harm was but I'll come
back to members with an update on the
employment land Supply issue as well
okay Council ball boys
thank you chair yes uh two questions
really just coming from um comments from
the parish council
um one is there's um
mention of a Footbridge over the A14
um
which doesn't appear to be sort of um
looked at in any any depth or as to
where it's going to be but the other
question
is is the the
um employment on the site is looking to
double from 300 to 600 there's no
comment from Anglia water because
there's no connection to the main sewage
system so my question is
um how is this going to be managed it's
a considerable number of people to be
looked at from a
safe and healthy point of view
so with regards to the full application
we only have 20 full-time new employees
being created so we're not seeing a jump
from 300 to 600 we see
we're seeing 300 to 320.
um and then with regards to plot e as
and when that comes forward we can
assess that at that point
um
just
getting into the annual monitoring
report to see if we have anything on the
employment land uh issue but I will come
back and it might be one that actually
the agent is able to provide
entity with regards to
um
sewage on site because from the top of
my head I can't answer that question for
you but again I'll try and find the
information for you members and report
back
thank you
and the Footbridge
with regards to the Footbridge we've got
quite a small
um
increase in the number of
employees being created
I'm not necessarily sure that the
Footbridge is required to mitigate the
impact of this development
um I'm not 100 sure whether the land to
cite the Footbridge would be within the
ownership of the applicant so she would
be then be creating a a third party
um land issue and nothing to that extent
has been raised by
um Suffolk highsways as a requirement to
mitigate the impact of the development
and we have no alteration of the public
right-of-way that runs north south
through the site as part of this
application this application is well off
to the East and would affect the run of
the public right-of-way would you remain
as it currently is
thank you thank you master Stringer yeah
thank you uh can you explain why this
site
doesn't have an access onto the A14
going east
uh can you also tell me where is the
Heritage assessment for all the list of
buildings in holy New Street
and also I noticed there's not a
there's not a mention from environmental
health
about the uh
the issues in holy New Street with hgvs
and residents
so no we don't have Heritage comment
with regards to listed buildings on holy
New Street and I also don't have comment
from environmental health with regards
to those buildings either
can I just ask the legal advisor and the
head of planning um you know we're
missing key information on an
application before us
which members are already at this early
stage asking where they are they're
feeling that the uh that that Daniel is
slightly compromised because he hasn't
got all the full information before him
is doing the best he can
um
it feels pretty unsatisfactory to me as
chair we actually proceed with this item
it's way early in but to me I mean we'll
keep going because we've got to follow
due process but
um can you just have a conflab about
whether actually we are able to make a
decision with so much information that
isn't before us and it's a lot of it is
hearsay
whether that's appropriate that we
continue with this item
[Music]
I will answer chairman do you want to
hear from other
I don't want to make similar point
well just very quickly chairman I mean I
absolutely agreement
what I'm going to say was the question
is would it be possible in order by
following due process in order to defer
it
until we get that information that's the
question I want to ask
I'll jump in now so that's your your
judgment to make as decision makers
we'll keep going we'll have to do that
after we've heard from all the speakers
we can't make that decision yet yeah
yeah sorry on um the neighborhood plan
you stating the report that there's no
conflict with warpit neighborhood plan I
note the area is allocated for potential
sites for housing and also note that
they support
um growth of industrial uses on
Brownfield sites I haven't looked
through the whole plan
but is this site actually allocated for
industrial site within their plan So
within the adopted development plan it's
not allocated
um but then the development of vaccine
transport pre-con and Truckee has all
come forward
in the intervening period it will be
allocated Within part one of the joint
local plan as that moves forward
I don't know that it's allocated within
the woolpit neighborhood plan
but they do have a policy with regards
to
provision of
um additional which notes preference for
Brownfield sites
but I think given the direction of the
mppf the mppf doesn't make that
distinction but also there would be a
certain spatial logic that went with if
we have additional hgv users it would be
beneficial in terms of resources to
direct them towards an existing
um
Park which has connection for HD which
really is do you still support that
there is no conflict with the notebook
neighborhood plan
yes
interesting thanks
okay any other questions for
clarification before we move on no okay
so we obviously can't get into debate
yet we need to hear from all the
relevant people then come decide how we
want to play that but if I could ask you
guys just to confirm before we get to
that point please so we'll now move on
um to question uh to uh speakers and we
have the parish council if you'd like to
come forward
um and we have a timer here we have you
have three minutes
uh Mr chair before you start your egg
timer
sorry but you really do need to do
something about the sound in here
we sitting at the back are at a
disadvantage we really cannot hear
mainly what the councilors say but it is
getting very difficult and I think
perhaps a little training on projecting
would be useful
but you can turn your egg timer over now
um I'm Julia ewins
um and I'm chair of the woolpit parish
council
um once again we see the planning system
using double standards
particularly in this case when dealing
with listed buildings the officers
report at 9.4 said that the inspector
had refused as a scaffolding site for
housing saying it was harmful to the
setting of lawn Farm
the inspector's report also said that
housing was not suitable on that site
because the only access would be by car
are these
um not the same for this development
proposed today in fact for the whole
development of Law and form
um the officer has given us lots of
lovely photographs of the site he has
not shown you any up-to-date photographs
there's a lot more building there than
there is in photographs and he has not
shown you the lighting which can
probably be seen from space by now
so I would urge you all to make a site
visit
and go at dusk to see the lights
at 4.1 in the office's report we are
told the A14 as a key hgv route
but this site is not only A14
yes there is access off the A14 to the
site
but if you wanted to get back on the A14
to roughly the set to wool pit it's a 12
mile round trip people are not making it
the officer says
that the hgv movements is strictly
controlled no it isn't
a few small signs saying quote
unsuitable for large vehicles does not
stop heavy traffic taking shortcuts and
that's to say nothing if the private car
movement
the woolpit neighborhood plan asks for
good access to the A14 it does not imply
any development would be acceptable
there must be better traffic management
please don't pass the buck on this local
residents our lives are being made
miserable
even the manager of one of the other
businesses already on the site is now
campaigning for the old A45 to have
speed limits on it
at 6.1 we are told the area will be for
outdoor storage
presumably these the items stored are
for sale
how many extra vehicle movements both in
and out of the site will this
incur
um the the local residents are going to
hear an awful lot of movements within
the site
um so I lost sentence please your time I
would I therefore that will put Parish
Council urges you to refuse this
permission thank you
thank you very much any questions at all
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you uh we'll now move on uh to uh we
have no objective no supporter but we
have the agent uh Jamie Martin Edwards
uh with James Bailey uh and Craig Smith
I think it says down here anyway
um so over to you and again three
minutes please
thank you chair good morning members my
name is Jamie Martin Edwards I'm a
senior planner with James bayden
planning James joins me today to answer
any questions that you may have
One Park Business Center is already
acknowledged as a suitable employment
site and sign posted off the A14 a key
strategic hgv route through the country
this has been established through a
number of previous applications and
through the made walpit neighborhood
plan
a holistic site has also been identified
as an employment allocation within the
emerge and Joint local plan and whilst
the jlp cannot be given signal
significant weight at the current time
wider area of Lawn Park Business Center
has been approved and developed on this
basis backed in Transport Services
pre-con products and Truck East have all
implemented their permissions on a
successfully operating out of the Lawn
Park Business Center with detailed
consent also in place for a further
building adjacent to the site the
application before members today is to
complete the change of use on the
remaining line of Lawn Park Business
Center this comes in a hybrid form with
parcel 4 already benefiting from an
extent outline consent under the
truckee's permission in 2019 a
successful site visit and
pre-application process with your
offices including planning Heritage and
economic development has led to Parcels
4 and 5 being submitted with full
details and proposes minimal boot form
by way of an office of a modest 142
square meters in size the rest of the
site will be open storage
with the A14 to the South the views to
the north of the site would have a
backdrop of the existing warehouses
belonging to bactum transport and
pre-com
the officer's recommendation sets out a
list of conditions that includes a
limitation to storage Heights the
applicant accepts this approach as it
will control and mitigate wider
landscape impacts that may arise if
storage heights were to exceed that of
the existing commercial buildings to the
north
plot 6 is included in the application as
an outline submission and completes the
remaining land available for commercial
use at Lombard Lawn Park Business Center
this has formed part of the application
to ensure the proposal takes an
interdisciplinary approach by utilizing
the drainage and internal access
infrastructure that the wider site
benefits from moreover a full
Landscaping strategy has been submitted
to the application that offers a
substantial buffer on the eastern
boundary of the site that is shared with
lawn Farm as well as expanding on
landscape scheme for The Wider site lawn
Farm is a grade 2 listed building and
the buffer offers significant mitigation
reducing the harm of to the setting of
the listed building to the lowest level
possible while still achieving the
economic benefits of The Proposal this
is in line with the mppf planning policy
guidance and considered acceptable buyer
officers I would therefore respectfully
request members endorse their officer's
recommendation and prove the application
today and between us we should be able
to answer any questions that you have
thank you chair and thank you members
thanks so much any questions cancer
Stringer yep thank you you stated that
this development was on an hgv route
could you explain what that is
uh the officer had a slide earlier that
shows the hgv route being the A14
and it's shown also with the green line
that any hdvs that need to come off the
A14 in this area are to follow the green
line and this site is on that route the
access goes straight onto that route
but the green line
is is not a designated Lorry root is it
this is the route that hgvs have to take
should they come off the designated
route of the A14 that's a different
answer to the question I proposed
the green root is not a designated Lorry
root because it is now no longer being
used for diversions when there are
closures I I respect that as an answer I
would say that there's not many other
sites that can get any closer to a route
that hgvs have to come off the A14 too
this is the closest you could get to
that side
okay thank you any other casterfield
to continue with that theme
the htvs can come off the A14 heading
east and use the old A45 there's no
access in the opposite direction they
have to go down to the next Junction the
whatever the holy Junction and join
there also they should the implication
from the parish comments and things is
in fact they don't they take shortcuts
through ball pit what what action is
being proposed to ensure that doesn't
happen
so the planning officer indicated
earlier in regards to conditions to
ensure that hgvs take a specific route
and that the landowner could take legal
action should any tenants on the sites
and their employees not take those
routes the landowner would be more than
happy to take that on as an acceptable
condition in this instance in terms of
The Wider Network the Warren Lane site
up into ellsworld was weight restricted
as is into the sense of warpit is my
understanding clearly employees if
they're not taking uh
do you care an attention to the road
signage then that is a matter that needs
to be taken up to businesses in terms of
their employees is not necessarily a
direct planning matter but we would
happily accept that condition as the
planning officer previously indicated to
thank you any other questions
okay thank you very much so now move on
to the ward member that we again have
two Ward members here so shall I go
first from councilor geek
okay so this is from Council of geek I'd
like to comment on three aspects firstly
traffic secondly the setting of the
listed buildings and thirdly Lighting
traffic as warpit Parish Council has
said in their consultation response it
will not be possible to control travel
routes to and from work for those
employed at this business park it is
easy to enter But impossible to leave
without driving through either elmsworld
wool pit or Hawley New Street past
houses fronting on the roads of these
Villages there's no public transport or
safe pedestrian access to the site
we say this every time there is a new
planning application in this area but
sad it never seems to have any effect
what's new this time is that bactum
transport one of the tenants on the
existing buildings and now trying to get
a reduced speed limit for the A14 exit
Road the old A45 their argument is that
the increasing volumes of traffic means
there is a developing risk of serious
accidents
such as becoming dangerous for you to
enter the area as well as unpleasant for
residents when you leave
the second point is around the setting
of the listed buildings
the late 6th 17th century lawn Farm may
have been built as a larger replacement
for the earlier 17th century lawn
Cottage the relationship of these
buildings to wallpaper heat is
interesting
both buildings were just off the edge of
the heath in the 18th century as shown
on the hodgkinson's map of 1783.
but built on land that was part of the
heath 200 years earlier as shown on the
Swinton Park map of 1568.
in the 1560s the heath clearly ran right
up to the edge of what is now holy Park
so the two buildings were probably built
as usual on what was at the time the
edge of the heath and they may mark an
early stage in the piecemeal enclosure
of the medieval Heath
at previous meetings to consider
developments in this area councilors
have commented that we've already
damaged the setting of these grade two
listed buildings so we we may as well
continue
equally in 2021 the appeal inspector for
the application to build five houses
close to lawn Farm said the development
has already undertaken at the business
park adjacent and has a negative effect
on the setting of the listed building
and it will eventually permanently erode
the relationship The Farmhouse
previously had with the open and
undeveloped fields to the West
these Open Fields to the West are or
perhaps I should say were the remains of
wool pit Heath
the inspector also said however that the
harm that would be caused to the setting
of lawn Farmhouse by other developments
would not justify further harm
and the further harm is exactly what has
been caused by this application
lighting
until Lawn Park Business Center began to
be built the outskirts of Warburton Elms
were along the A14 to the east consisted
of an attractive tree Fringe Greenfield
with wide views of classic Suffolk
Farmhouse sorry of a classic Suffolk
Farmhouse and the listed building of
lawn Farm
which is now a grim industrial landscape
with Bleak sheds and row after row of
lorries and harsh lighting that appears
to be on 24 hours a day
when you cycle past on the smaller roads
at Night the Lights are blinding the
light pollution is affecting the whole
of both Villages and goodness knows how
the wildlife is faring
this is despite the fact that we were
given to understand from previous
applications that the lighting was the
minimum possible
so if you're minded to approve this
application please can we not have any
increase in light pollution
if extra lighting has to be found for
this new area please can there be a quid
pro quo in reducing the overall glare
which is both harmful and unpleasant
that's from councilor geek now hand over
to you councilor master
uh thank you I cannot support any
further commercial development in this
location without any improvements to
Junction 47a of the A14 to make it a
proper full access Junction in both
directions
the reports suggests that there is good
access for hgvs already established with
the other companies already operating at
long Farm but there is only access from
the eastbound carriageway of the A14
traffic leaving the site must turn right
onto the old A14 A45 and hgvs have to go
all the way to topped Hill to get back
on the A14 in either direction and this
adds over six miles to any westbound
Journey so it's not surprising that um
vehicles are making alternative routes
whilst the large hgvs that are currently
using the site are tracked they will be
making the proper diversion but it maybe
it isn't the hgvs that we have to worry
about
um it's the ones that are up to 7.5
tonnes which are not restricted on
Warren Lane
so smaller Vehicles will be tempted to
use the minor roads through the Villages
of elmswell or wool pit uh you know it's
inevitable they don't want to do a six
mile diversion so Warren Lane elmsworld
does have a 7.5 ton weight restriction
so largest vehicles are not able to use
it legally but it is the number of
smaller lorries which general public
find it very difficult to tell the
difference between a under 7.5 ton Lorry
and an over 7.5 ton Lorry so we
regularly get
um people saying there are lorries using
Warren Lane they'll be the ones that are
under 7.5 tons and they are still pretty
big
um it is a narrow single Lay Road as we
have discussed in the previous
application with a handful of pretty
useless passing places and no pedestrian
path
in the other direction from lawn Farm we
have Wood Lane and what Wood Road and
Warren Lane wall pit they do not have
the benefit of any weight restriction
and are regularly used by large vehicles
if these vehicles want to head West on
the A14 and they end up going through
the middle of wool pit there is an
almost hairpin corner where they need to
turn right at the bottom of Warren Lane
and whilst the A14 overnight closures
were in place a few months ago a lorry
taking this route
took out a telegraph pole on that corner
cutting off the residents of that part
of wall pit from the telephone and
interconnection for several days
um whilst the companies on the site use
the GPS trackers to monitor their own
trucks there's no control over visiting
hdvs so unless the highways are
Authority ban the use of Wood Lane and
Warren lanes for all but cars and small
Vans this development should not proceed
uh the as we've heard before the
existing companies on the site are
already campaigning for road safety
measures to be put in place as vehicles
coming directly off the A14 at speed
near the junction where large lorries
are trying to turn right it is an
accident waiting to happen
enough said about the traffic issues the
development is a blot on the landscape
from the edge of elmsworld from the top
of Warren Lane previously rural view is
now swamped by large sheds
um okay so we're getting used to them in
the daylight but at night it is
something else the lighting is
completely over the top Bright Lights
must be causing so much light pollution
I dread to think how the wildlife are
coping any further development on this
site must not increase this invasive
lighting
Our Heritage officers seem to think that
this is only going to cause a low level
of less than substantial harm to the two
listed buildings adjacent to the site I
find that very difficult to believe
the plot this plot wraps itself
completely around those two listed
farmhouses
how can that not affect the setting of
the list of buildings and they're linked
to the surrounding Farmland if you are
considering granting this permission I
would urge you to take a site visit just
to see how invasive this development
will be
and then we hear that there's only going
to be 20 full-time equivalent jobs is
that sufficient benefit to outweigh all
the harm of this development
and that harm is mainly from the
deliveries to and from the site not the
employees on the site thank you
any questions for the ward member
thank you very much so members we've had
all the information put before us
a time for us to discuss and Rich
conclusion do we feel we have all the
information required from an officer
perspective full of committee to make a
decision
beautiful
well I was going to say did you want
five minutes just I think I would check
through
just put a halt on the meeting for a
couple minutes to let the officer speak
if you do leave the room we'll start
again at 25 past but if you do leave the
room please do not talk about the
application to anyone until we come back
into the room thank you
foreign
welcome back thank you the officers had
a chance to have a quick uh catch up and
discussion on this could you just fill
this in please yeah of course we were
just reviewing the advice given and the
comments we've had and I think we're
content that we have had advice from the
various consultes albeit that that might
have been in pre-app as as Daniel
explained the changes in the meantime
hadn't been so significant to affect
that and that again we had both um
County highways and National highways
advice that we're content to proceed
with the recommendation if members felt
that but equally if you felt that a
deferral for a further update of that
advice on Heritage and highways Grounds
was something you would prefer that
equally that is within your
to make and that we would take that away
and come back with an update of advice
um and of course with the update from
landscape and ecology at the same time
that we're currently waiting for
yes I made sure I think it's as you're
aware it's very com quite common for you
to have a report like today's that says
not we recommend
uh that you resolved to grab permission
but that you recommend to delegates the
chief planning officer subject to X and
Y being sorted out in
in this case is landscape and ecology
but it's entirely within your discretion
as the decision makes and say well no
we're not doing that we want to hear
from them in full that's a later date
with the full it's a bit different
because on ecology I accept all of that
but on Heritage there are specific
points that people have raised which we
haven't actually been addressed such as
impact
in other Villages just outside the site
but that would be for members to decide
okay well thank you for that feedback so
members I'm going to open it up to you
to discuss and come to a conclusion of
what we want to do today Council
Passmore you had your hand up first
thank you well chairman having listened
to what we've just been advised I do
understand
um the officer's view but I have to say
I think in this particular case I would
like to move for deferral because I do
think we need to have proper details
particularly on the Heritage side and I
don't personally feel comfortable Others
May differ of course making your
decision with what we've got in front of
us because it is sensitive we've heard
various issues and if there is a
resolution for this
um then that's fine but I do I would be
uncomfortable making that decision with
the information we've got I certainly
would like to have more detailed
information on that on the Heritage side
in particular and travel routes etc for
hgvs so therefore I'm moving to defer
until we have the information and listen
to others I've got councilman excellent
Council field
I'm happy you support
Council of passports um
proposal I'd also I would like to see
from the Heritage team a comment around
noise I know that's an environmental
issue but if I'm sat in my listed
property and I
storage site has got eight um forklift
trucks beat in all day is that not
impacting the
um the Heritage asset so I'd like a bit
more around that
as well thank you
thank you yes I agree with those points
I'd also add the thoughts that lighting
is obviously a really significant issue
impacting on amenity one would like to
see a real solution to that as was
stated perhaps a reduction in what
exists as well as ensuring that what is
new provided meets the needs of wildlife
human beings and various other
interested bodies so a real solution to
that issue and the same thing I feel
with traffic we're talking about hgvs
um we we want to be certain that if we
allow this to go ahead that their HTV
will be controlled not just those that
are owned by particular companies and
have trackers but hgvs in general I also
feel the issue of
substantial Vehicles which don't quite
meet the hgv
classification and their incursion on
Warren Lane and and going down and
through
warpit itself as ways of avoiding
diversions of substantial length needs
to be addressed I fully understand that
highways can't refuse an application
unless it has a
severe impact on the on the local
network
but this certainly has a severe impact
on local residents and
I can't see personally that we can't
move some substantial Direction in to
addressing that impact
and you know we have to find somewhere
for employment locations it might be
good if we could address the issues of
this site and get them resolved to the
satisfaction of residents and also one
I'm preaching you know to me that
impacts other areas as well we all
suffer from various areas we want to see
some form of development and we
absolutely need to ensure that that
doesn't make the lives of local people a
misery so some
effective action which would be proposed
would be great and cancer Stringer thank
you chair so I want to take a little
while uh I I did ask if the I think that
it's surreal in that I've had a number
of emails about the former A14 overnight
and I got a picture of the former A14
last night which I would would like to
share with you just to show why there's
some questions we ought to be asking
okay I'll ask them verbally then you'll
have to take my word uh the it was
ironic that uh that we haven't got the
figures of how much land we've allocated
for business and employment the last
time we looked at the uh when we were
going through the constellation of the
jop I think just before then we've got
almost double our allocation which was
why we were allocating some of our
former employment sites for housing as
we did in stowmarket opposite Gateway 14
which is now of course a substantial
employment site
what I want to mention is what's missing
what's missing are the other two Ward
members I.E the members of Hawley
and whether and weatherden the
immediately you turn right out of this
site you're in that Ward
and the hgv route for everything leaving
this site
goes through a little tiny Hamlet called
holy New Street where are there are a
load of listed buildings medieval style
jetted up to the former A45
where when there is a diversion in here
they leave and go and stay in a hotel
because of the disruption to their lives
that our environmental health Team know
about but is not in this report
there are also the issues of the former
A14
immediately you turn it right out of
this site you are entering a road where
all of the drainage failed five years
ago
and there is no plan to renew it so when
it rains the road runs like a river so
overnight of course that's frozen so we
now have a skating rink outside here you
then have the Quarry
which after nine years of operation we
still have not successfully been managed
to keep get them to keep to their
conditions last night we lost three
windscreens on that road to my knowledge
the other people have emailed me with
broken windscreens from the debris in
that road
we lost the curb age on the former A14
about three and a half years ago it's
now buried under three feet of aggregate
and the road is being narrowed every
single day a bit more rubbish Landing
that road and it's narrowed the email I
have today from the enforcement officer
of the County Council this morning is we
better call the environment agency and
the police and look at whether we need
to shut this road
this is the HG Road the only route out
of this site as this proposal this right
this this is going to be a sustainable
development this site needs a row a root
out straight onto the A14 it is not
sustainable to allow any more expansion
to this site without that routing so if
we I don't I could easily move reviews I
won't I will go along with the deferral
but we need to look at all of these
issues
I know that the level of EXT outstanding
complaint about this road is phenomenal
yet it's not mentioned in the
correspondence from the County Council
this has to be bottomed out before we
get anywhere near approving adding more
weight to an existing bad situation if
the existing tenants on what we've just
granted are saying we need safety
improvements we're worried about the
safety here that should be warning
enough to be careful before we go any
further so I'll gladly
go along with the deferral so long as we
look at all of those other issues as
well thank you chair thank you very much
okay anyone else wish to speak or we're
happy to go to the vote Yes Council
so it's been proposed by a councilman
Passmore seconded by Council mayor that
we go to defer and I think we've heard
all the reasons why I'm sure
can make the list of that and bring that
back
happy to hand over to you
thank you chair so if I just read what I
have got for you members which is the
application number DC
2204002 we defer to enable the officers
to obtain further advice from Heritage
including holy nursery and noise
highways including Travel HD reroutes
and incursions of smaller vehicles on
wool pit and Warren Lane and a solution
to lighting of an update on landscape
and ecology
everyone's happy honest right now
thank you councilor field can I take
your vote thank you
thank you members chair that is six
votes for deferral okay thank you thanks
very much okay so we'll move on uh plan
to move straight onto the next item
which is 7c which is 11 Market oh Andrew
should we do the last one next and then
you can stay let's do that let's swap it
around so that
I don't know
okay sorry we'll go straight into we'll
stay ask you to leave Andrew because the
case officer isn't here so we'll go
straight into 7c stone the 11
Marketplace Stow Market
and we have a case officer Thomas Pinner
who's here to introduce the application
Daniel you've left your water
okay so Thomas printer over to you to
introduce the item thank you
thank you chair
so this is our application
dc2205717 11 Marketplace uh stowmarket
uh so here is the site
um so we're adjacent to the central
Marketplace uh area in stowmarket
um we have uh the building in question
and enter the rear is the jump Hill
Center for Creative Arts
um so this is a former NatWest
um
West Bank
and then I uh further out uh position
location of the site shown in the box
there
um and this is the the red line site
plan
position of the site
and then we have the the constraints so
I'm just trying to use this
um the building equations is there
um so it's much it's grade two listed
um and within Star Market Conservation
area which is shown in the blue hatch
Zone and then we've got numerous other
list of buildings not directly attached
but in close proximity
um and then we go into some of the
proposed plans
um so we've got a proposal for
replacement and removal of roof lights
and and a replacement of sections of a
flat roof
um so these are just some detailed
sections of the the roof the new
um areas of roof the the Junctions and
so this is some of the areas to be
replaced uh it's very shallow pitched um
felt roof in ineffective flat
um so purpose of this and some of the
details of the Junctions with a pitch
adjacent
we've got um we've plans showing the
position of uh the roof lights to be
replaced so I believe we've got
um
it's uh there's four roof lights and a
roof hatch to come out
um and free roof lights will go in in
the position of free of the existing
roof lights but a smaller scale and then
we've got some
areas hatched maybe difficult to see in
this plan but um for some minor
replacement of of slates on the main
pitch of the roof here we've got some
repairs required and then the flat roof
area is a section abutting the between
on this building but abatting the the
John peel Center to the rear
um that which you'll see in the next
slide and some photos which may be
clearer
just as a small stretch or flat roof
where it's supposed to strip the roof
covering on that area and replace with a
new material
and then we've got some of the
photographs and look for the plans off
the site so bottom left is the building
as you see it from Marketplace
um and then we've got some aerial shots
of some of the roof the roof lights that
come out to be replaced
um and on the on the top right
um the second or the left hand of those
pictures is the section of flat roof to
be replaced
um replacement would be from felt to a
single ply membrane
is in a small picture in the center of
of the kind of roof material
um and we do also have details of the
proposed roof lights which is a
conservation style roof light which
which I did add in the design access
statement
and then it's just a photo from the the
rear so we've got the John pill Center
in the foreground and then building
the left part of the scaffolding is just
to show what you can see from church
walk to the to the rear of the site
um so having assessed this application
as
um as a Heritage officer
um have determined that the works would
not be harmful there wouldn't be any
loss of any historic fabric
um the proposed materials would be
appropriate to the nature of this list
of building
um you know um constraint is ecology and
we have comments from our ecology
consultant to say that they have no um
objections with the proposal we also
have comments from the town councilors
say they have no issues
uh so yes therefore the recommendation
is therefore for approval
thank you thank you very much
okay any questions for the case officer
do you have to cancel the field
you just be clearly at the office I
think they're worried about bats in the
roof or something they they're saying
they aren't any are they or just they're
not worried if we can move them out yes
so
um yeah the concern would be regarding
bats um a premium Roost assessment has
been submitted as partly application and
to the detail about ecology have said
there's no reason for objection based
upon that they do request an informative
so that when the works do take place if
and when the works take place
um care would be taken to ensure no bats
or roof um that rooms to harm at that
point
and there were some pictures somewhere
of um this is a section of flat roof
you're replacing there was a picture of
a roof somewhere with um
whatever we call it ridges on them the
way they used to do the sort of leg
roofs I just one where that was and
you're happy that
the appearances match and there's no
problems
uh yeah if I can get the um presentation
up and go back to the
pictures
um so the the majority of the the roof
of the building is a pitch slate roof
um if you can see it on the uh this plan
it's just this area at the rear of the
building along this um stretch here and
just come around this corner a little
bit is where where the building of bats
the adjacent
um buildings there's a section of raised
flat roof section currently in felt
which is a very modern not particularly
sympathetic material for a historic
building of this nature the replacement
would be a single ply membrane which is
a fairly modern style material but it's
um aesthetically probably improvement
over Overfelt and it's not it seems
unlikely to be a this is a historic part
of the roof it seems an attempt to
create a
perhaps a better weathering detail with
the adjacent building so this small
section has been added on at some
type like that
thank you
okay
no other questions so we'll move on
um on this one so we don't have the
parish council we don't have a projector
supporter we have the applicant who's
Kate Parliament Lawrence Lauren Frost
Stevens who I think are just here to
answer questions rather than to make a
statement and the ward member councilor
epignon has given his apologies and
confirmed no objections
so members of substitute discuss debate
and come to a conclusion
who would like to go first Council
plasma well I'm actually I think this is
fairly straightforward chairman now and
I appreciate John's questions there and
I think um planning officers have done a
good job as I don't really have any any
questions actually
um so I'd actually like to move approval
of the recommendation I'm not wishing
the West waste your time over there but
unless there's anything particularly
want to say I can't see anything wrong
with this application so that's why I'd
like to formally move approval
Casa mayor you're happy to secondly
improve
that's why he got his hand up
anyone else wish to speak or we'll go to
the boat we'll go to the vote thank you
thank you chair members that vote is in
progress councilor field
yay
thank you members chair that's uh six
votes for that's carried
okay
okay thank you very much
um we'll just wait for cancer Stringer
to come back
he's probably actually in the county
council's members area
okay everyone so welcome back Andrew to
now move on to the final application
before us which is um
dc2206013 127 Poplar Hill Stone Market
and I'll hand over to the case officer
Lily calm
the item to committee
awesome thank you good morning members
the item you are being asked to consider
is a householder application for the
construction of a dropped curb and
vehicular hard standing to the front of
127 Poplar Hill
um this is to accommodate the needs of a
disabled resident
okay
so this is the red line site plan which
shows the site and the size of the site
is approximately 1
386 square meters the application site
currently hosts a detached bungalow
um so this slide shows the an aerial
view of the site and the surrounding
area
the site is located in an established
residential area
this slide shows a larger scale aerial
photograph which shows the site in its
wider context
the slide shows the constraint map as
you can see there are no constraints on
the site however to the east of the site
there is a small public footpath
and this slide shows the proposed block
plan so the proposal would create a new
vehicular hard standing
um to the front of the dwelling and a
vehicular access of Poplar Hill which
would run across the existing footpath
and the grass Verge
um the existing footpath would be
lowered and finished in tarmac it is
proposed to meet current Highway
standards to allow a vehicle to pass
over without causing too much damage
um the next slide shows a further plan
detailing the proposed access and
vehicular hard standing
the hard sign would measure
approximately six meters by 3.6 meters
and the footpath is to remain the same
width and material
um yes this is to ensure the needs of
pedestrians are met
this next slide shows the visibility
splays The Proposal details a 45 meter
vehicular visibility splay and a two
meter pedestrian visibility display in
both directions
and this is just further details of the
proposed parking Bay
um the proposed materials include the
use of a permeable Paving block
um specifically called form pave
aquaflow
now we're moving on to some photographs
of the site this is the dwelling
and this is
um
the neighboring dwellings
this picture shows the grass Verge and
the footpath
and then the road
and this photo looks onto the opposite
direction
and this is opposite from the site
so moving on to recommendations the
recommendation is to Grant planning
permission with conditions as specified
in your table in your papers sorry thank
you thanks very much I've just got a
question really
um so can you just talk about because
obviously from the photos you've shown
this will be the first of to break the
sort of mold of a front garden with a
fence in front of each of the Bungalows
so it's kind of the first to do this
um is it is the policy that allows it
because of the need of the could you
just explain the policy that allows us
to do that because there is a sort of
sensitivity that there is a street scene
with none of them having done this and
this would be the first just just so
um Gemma to elaborate a bit because I'm
not too sure on the policy
um so we're looking at the character of
the area com compared and contrast to
your highways policies which support
provision of parking so there's not an
explicit yes you can definitely do it or
no you definitely shouldn't it is that
consideration of the character of the
area the the fact that it is for a
disability it's a difficult one you do
have to slightly weigh that in the
planning balance it is a benefit
um compared to the potential risk to
that stretch of Bungalows I think the
thing is the stretch bungalows
is only a few of them it's not the
complete street scene it's not a whole
Street either side where there aren't
any and this would be the first there
are that run there is this one that we
would then add in but in the wider area
there are accesses and on street parking
and a variety of mixed frontages so that
we're not suggesting that that would be
harmful in itself
this isn't attached to the resident who
lives there so this is a permanent this
is a permanent condition where we're not
suggesting that it would be ripped up
should the resident move that's the
consideration for members as if we are
happy with that essentially yeah for as
long as it lasts okay thank you very
much
um could I just ask is there any
designated parking currently for that
row of Bungalows on the aerial view it
looks like there might be a parking
space behind but are they actually
linked with those Bungalows or is that
just a public parking area
and to my knowledge there
and also if there was designated parking
the resident would need parking to be
quite close to the entrance because they
are disabled
castlefield
the same point really yes and observed
there are parking places called an
extensive car park behind the bound
Globe does land rise in that direction
is it is it too impossible
for someone with disabilities to to exit
the rear of the Bungalow compared with
exit in the front
I comment by the way that if you do look
at the streets in Google there are other
buildings down that line that have got
front axis slightly surprising because
highways usually doesn't like you having
to back out into a moment but uh
repeat the needs of a disabled person
but the real question is about the rear
is is it higher or is it on a the
sanction of the level at the moment
I'm not aware of that I haven't been
given any detail about the levels to the
back but I can definitely check for you
okay anyone else wish to ask questions
no okay so
um uh we do not have uh any one from the
Town Council or no objective supporter
no applicant I haven't had received
anything from the two Ward members
so it's over us to discuss debate and
come to a conclusion members
cancer Stringer so shy uh very simple
well-explained application uh it's you
know it's a slam dunk I think the
Americans call it uh I'll move approval
thank you Council field
the basis that there are other premises
down this
our particular Highway that have similar
sort of treatment so it's not
degrading the street saying to any
extent and
believing that whoever the person with
disabilities have they've probably
considered the rear exit and they're
probably our problems that have not been
spelled out to us okay clearly thank you
okay so it's been proposed by uh uh
Council during a second by Council field
anyone else wish to speak no okay so
we'll go to a vote please
chair members that votes in progress
councilor field
okay
I'm so glad
thank you members chair that's um seven
votes for thank you thank you very much
okay uh agenda item number eight is site
inspections do any site inspection
requests need to be reported to the
committee
procedure okay well thank you very much
I uh closed the meeting at 11 59. thank
you very much everyone